roccat ont beau carton perspective vos
cartons ça va être sur ces gens les
choristes
non ça c'est vraiment un film magnifique
effectivement en plus c'est en une
histoire vraie fin christian carion a
très très bien réussi son saut de son
pari quoi de parler de sas qui
synthétise très très bien ce qui s'est
passé et que c'est pas dans les livres
d'histoire ça qui est étonnant on n'a
pas pu tourner en france parce que les
militaires dans un premier temps accepté
qu'on tombe sur un terrain militaire
français les généraux ont lu le scénario
ils nous ont refusé le tournage qui a
été reculée
on a été énormes on n'a toujours pas
qu'on en parle on est obligé d'aller
tourner en roumanie
ouais et voilà et c'est cesser c'est un
moment magnifique c'est ils ont fait
l'europe avant tout le monde
ils seront du compte deux ils ont fait
ils ont fait preuve de libre arbitre en
fait ces hommes qui étaient
conditionnées à la haine de la race
étrangère sont leurs on leur apprenait
des poèmes ce qu'on voit dans le film au
début les pouilles les poésies des
enfants on dit il faut exterminer la
race allemande ce sont des assassins des
violeurs des égorgeurs et et il avait ça
dans la tête il se disait qu'en face
c'était des monstres et en fait ils sont
ils se sont arrêtés à noël 1914 et ils
ont dit non grâce à la musique
d'ailleurs quand l'ami richard d'un
ténor allemand et sa voix là et
le la cornemuse écossaise répond et d'un
seul coup la musique serait comme elle
est universelle la rencontre secret quoi
et il fera ils font preuve de libre
arbitre
ils savent que que ça va leur être fatal
et ils ont le courage de fraterniser et
ces gens qui étaient considérés comme
des lâches et des traîtres en fait
étaient des visionnaires et des ombres
et courageux et dérives les héros c'est
dans cette guerre de 14 qui a été quand
même là la fin de l'europe
on a envoyé se faire tuer des
générations entières de jeunes gens de
20 ans a tué l'europe l'europe plus
jamais été ce qu'elle a il est avant
c'était des millions de morts pour rien
puisque on se battait contre les
allemands bons et et ce film d'un seul
coup c'est une antidote extraordinaire à
ce poison qu'est la guerre et cette
scène quelques je trouve magnifique qui
résume bien le film qui est très très
belle et kiev qui est vrai qu est
réellement existé qui montrent bien
l'absurdité de cette guerre comme
beaucoup de bière c'est que ils ont
fraternisé et ils ont dit on arrête
maintenant on a fêté noël nouvel an on a
espéré la nourriture on a fait des
matches de foot on est où on va on va se
mettre
on recommence à se battre et le
lendemain il yal officiellement et c'est
une histoire vraie il arrive au bord des
tranchées françaises
il a failli se faire tuer d'ailleurs
parlé par les tireurs et le l'officier
français du 10 mai on aurait pu vous
tirer dessus on a dit qu ont recommencé
à se battre il dit non je viens vous
voir parce que on va vous bombardez de
l'arrière dans 10 minutes et je vous
propose de venir vous abritez chez nos
frères il ya les soldats français et
anglais écossais qui vont s'abriter dans
les tranchées allemandes et le français
vient une demi-heure plus tard en disant
on va riposter
venez chez nous à venir tour à l'amiable
dans les écoles ce film voilà c'est ce
qu'ils voient là un film montre shoah
dans les écoles c'est très bien il faut
aussi montrer ce film pour que les gens
voient ce que c'était cette guerre de
tranchées et voit comment des hommes ont
résisté à ça c'est un très grand film
allez-y là vous perdez pas un niveau de
pognon niveau de temps c'est génial
garder son libre arbitre ça se perd
beaucoup moins égaux
l'actualité façon le discours de
lévesque voit la fin du film l'été rire
est un discours de bush ouais du
président bush s'est il a repris le
discours de l'époque
oui la guerre du bien contre le mal
l'extermination de la race l'étranger
enfin
et vous alors vous d'un seul coup ça y
est on découvre que derrière le comique
aux oreilles décollées
il ya un acteur aux oreilles décollées
excellent vraiment excellent dans le
film guillaume canet très bien aussi un
vraiment très émouvant guillaume il est
au bord des larmes du début à la fin du
film et c'est vraiment très bien diane
kruger aussi enfin vraiment c'est tout
le monde est bien anciens films comment
dirais-je assez classique à dents ça
dans sa facture après si c'est pas un
film moderne
c'était un film un peu traditionnelle
même très lyrique enceinte c'est la
qualité française un peu kitsch même
mais c'est très puissant un certain
moment on se demande comment ces films
et quoi on a on regarde avait pris par
le tenait dans l'émission s'appelle
des rameaux jours julie ferrier oui je
suis allé la voir un spectacle l'année
dernière oui j'étais là pour aller au
petit palais des glaces
elle est géniale ray elle m'a fait
penser à zhouqu
elle met dans son dans le padd
l'invention dans le délire dans elle est
géniale et voilà d'ailleurs elle fait ma
première partie à l'olympia à partir du
5 au 10 km 10 fois et l'ogre le chabab a
téléphoné en disant il faut aller la
voir ça génial si on m'a dit ça ouais
mais au bout d'un moment c'est vrai j'y
vais au bout d'un moment on va dire
attention dany bull est en 2e partie de
julie ferrier l'olympia c'est quand
l'olympia à partir du 5 mars
non ce à partir de lait 5 avril c'était
quoi alors que tu dis ça en deuxième
partie de julie ferrier
alors comment ça va avec et à elle très
bien ses cuisses un serial killer du
serial zikeurs parce que c'est un enfant
encore on a un bébé vrai mais combien
d'enfants que j'ai trois enfants avec
trois femmes différentes
c'est possible je vais vérifier ou et
non avec oui oui et débarqué je vais
rien lui et vous vous faites des enfants
sans me marier obligatoirement près et
c'est leur journal on est mariés
on est très heureux et elle m'en faire
pleins me portent beaucoup effectivement
chante plus que chance elle me rend très
heureux et c'est une femme merveilleuse
vous allez découvrir parce que je pense
qu'il ya elle va faire le blind test
vous allez à fortement vous avez ramer
dur pour la séduire non oui j'ai ramé
way ah ouais j'ai ramé et surtout comme
en général quand on j'ai testé une boîte
où il y avait un concert de jazz et le
patron m'accueille il me fait un boom
mais vedette c'est bien mais il y avait
un bar et je voyais à elle au bar avec
son prince une amie ayda au concert
jeudi je vais aller au bar habibou et
ils montrent que j'arrive à quand même
allé au bar ils voient que je regarde
d'y aller j'étais halluciné par voilà
leur labeur
il est allé la voir sans me demander en
disant tu veux que je te présente deux
baby boom et elle a fait non non je vois
pourquoi non et voilà j'ai fait c'est
génial